l'association québécoise des sports
demande la réouverture des 146 pas sur
le territoire fermé depuis le 20
décembre
plus de la moitié des établissements
affirment avoir enregistré des pertes de
plus de 200 mille dollars depuis un mois
selon l'association aucune explosion n'a
été rapporté dans les établissements
depuis le début de la pandémie avec nous
ce soir jocelyna dubuc présidente
fondatrice du spa eastman madame du big
band soir
vous est fermé depuis le 20 décembre
l'espace ont fermé depuis le 20 décembre
pourquoi est-ce que vous êtes d'avis que
cette fermeture la et injuste n'est pas
approprié mais a fait nous parce que
l'hébergement à l'hôtellerie on est
ouvert mais toute la sélection des bains
est fermé alors dans l'industrie qui ont
des bains mais c'est fermé la seule
chose qui va être ouvert ça va être le
massage
et ce qui est un peu une aberration
c'est que je regarde je si si on à
l'intérieur la piscine intérieure est
ouvert par contre nos abeilles qui sont
à l'extérieur nos gars l'extérieur sont
fermés alors qu'on se retrouve la blague
l'hygiène yoda qui domine on est
d'ailleurs complètement et la majorité
des isp à jeudi dans des grandes
installations techniquement c'est
difficile mais grande piscine chauffée
et d'autre part on sait à quel point que
ça apporte du bonheur du bien-être aux
clients de pouvoir faire de la
thermothérapie
la moitié des établissements 52 % des
établissements disent avoir perdu plus
de 200 mille dollars depuis le 20
décembre mais est ce que c'est votre cas
également vous fonctionner à peu à perte
en ce moment complètement je dire à noël
c'était de l'edge kacou ya eu lieu jeudi
à partir du 20 août a dégringolé on
attendait comme on dit beaucoup de
plaisir chez nous qu'ils des gens qui
venaient pour une semaine et là tout à
coup bas on doit fermer alors ça a été
une gestion des opérations
exploits des employés parce qu'on a pas
une goutte y perde ça a été tellement
dur au début de la pandémie en a fermé
trois mois et là on a vu des cas
d'employés des gens qui sont à la
rassurer économiquement et là on a
reconstruit une équipe extraordinaire
incluant des dérapages la cuisine des
serveurs est à nouveau tout à coup tout
se rétrécit est ce que vous êtes où vous
allez avoir des mises à pied
c'est à dire qu on a d'une certaine
façon c'est à dire qu'on contrôle les
horaires on les met à temps partiel de
sacs garder un lien avec l'entreprise et
puis ça se place de l'ena papier on veut
parler là c'était ton de dire combien de
jours qui viennent travailler puis
évidemment il ya comme ce soir donc un
client alors que bon la semaine face il
y en avait 15 qui était en télétravail
et notre but c'est juste des femmes
cavani doucement quelle image hyper
nouveau madame vous êtes une précurseur
dans le monde des sports ou au québec
lors vous interrogé à plusieurs reprises
qu'elle est deux ans après la pandémie
l'as fait deux ans que ça dure comment
vous voyez l'avenir de cette industrie
n'est ce pas
ce que j'ai l'impression c'est qu'on va
découvrir à quel point l'industrie des
sports peut faire du bien aux gens cette
notion juste du chaud et du froid qu'on
connaissait pas les norvégiens pratiquer
puis d'une façon intensive et là on est
en train de réaliser que des outils pour
se mettre en forme pour être bien pour
gérer le stress et je vous dirai au
niveau du stress tous ceux qui ont fait
la thermothérapie
c'est magique qui se passe vous l'avez
peut-être d'expérimenter cette notion de
transpirer présidente moi c'est magique
puisque sa chute mais est-ce que vous
pensez que la pandémie va contrecarrer
le développement des spas ou au
contraire ça pourrait être une occasion
pour accélérer leur développement
personnellement je crois que c'est une
si on arrive à passer la bague qui en a
peut-être fait pour ça qu'ils vont
fermer et puis j'ai réussi on a tenu en
a perdu peut-être la moitié des maçons
rappeur lefa noir gagner mais ce que je
vois c'est par contre ceux qui
appliquent maintenant c'est déjà très
engagé dans la santé grand soin d'eux il
va travailler dans un environnement qui
fait du bien ils sont sensibles à
l'offre alimentaire qu'on fait et la
population ce que j'ai remarqué dans la
dernière année france était ouvert j'ai
jamais eu autant de nouveaux clients qui
viennent pour 4000 5000 semaine alors
qu'avant il y avait des pressions
viendra juste pour une journée et que
c'est assez non ils ont le goût de se
déploie avec une sensibilité se
développer car à part comme apprenti ne
soit qu est ce que vous demandez madame
dubuc au gouvernement ce soir
crealys confettis la solution
c'est là on fait partie de la solution
nos deux personnes hyper stressé qui
vient pas c'est un art deux heures pour
prendre un sauna qui va dans les bains
qui voit dans le foie qui retourne chez
lui en suisse
mais il paraît qu'on perd quand thierry
de la maison épi pareil comme mère parce
qu'un niveau de stress fondamentale qui
large et les gens besoin de ça besoin du
contact la nature la majorité de nos
sports sont construits dans des
environnements magnifiques
si on parle de 10 of reverie faut que
les écoles est un système de ventilation
qu'aurélie nous c'est comme c'est
intégrer ça fait partie de notre adn
c'est là ok et
alors considéré nous comme faisant
partie de la sédition parfait padam dieu
merci d'avoir été avec nous ce soir ça
m'a fait plaisir
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit
oh